okay so when the Vikings advanced the
playoffs were likely able to get this
guy on and he's like oh man and then
that's not in because he's got to stay
in Minnesota to sit in the same seat to
watch the Niners and the Vikings game
because clearly where he positioned
himself is what put the Vikings over the
top in the Superdome he's one of our
favorites he is the comedian and actor
and very funny man Nick Swardson how are
you Nick
hi I'm this guy this guy yeah so thanks
for having me back rich and yeah I
decided to stay in Minnesota you were
very gracious enough to let me and stay
let you I mean like I mean I committed
you did at the last second I was I had
my bags and I was ready to go and I'm
like hey is there any chance because
everybody was giving me flak for it
they're like why you're Lee button but
you gotta stay because we have another
game so I was like all right then my
voice changed yeah I'm not going
anywhere so I stayed at my home bar the
corner bar in Minneapolis which is
awesome shadow bill hey and they save me
my same seat and everything and so I
don't usually buy into that like
mysticism but once with the Vikings we
we've been so just brainwashed and like
oh like we'll have that great crazy
playoff play right
Minneapolis miracle all that stuff and
then we just totally buy into it and
then we're all in so it's like this
wizard who's like here's a golden castle
everyone's like no and then the next
week it's like yeah it's an igloo made
out of turds it just fools us every time
so I sat in the seat and everyone's so
used to it so it was just you know we
had a decent first half when we scored
that touchdown Diggs
at 7-7 because Jimmy G just storm right
down a field first 15 yeah looked like
you were gonna get the doors blown off
yeah and then all of a sudden it's 77
and you might be liking that again old
Kirk Cousins situation yeah then we go
into the half I believe you know it was
closer things 14 10 through that pick
towards the end of the half yeah maybe
make it a two but score game but he
couldn't do it because he couldn't do it
and then once we I mean we just never
had a run game I mean that was a big red
flag I mean if I weren't such a homer I
would have picked that outcome
essentially be right san francisco's
defense is just so good BOCES just
horrifying and we had no run game I mean
it was just insane and that's obviously
the crucial aspect of the team with
talent comes crucial aspect in cousins I
like cousins a lot it's a good
quarterback and but he's you know he's
not mobile and he doesn't thing we're
like he'll just he'll just collapse you
know if the pocket comes in he's just
like bye you know which is fine turd
Turkoglu is that might be one of our
fantasy team names for next you got
that's not a bad right yes but yeah it
was it was fine so now again mix words
mix warts in here in the retest row so
you literally sat in the same seat yeah
that you did to watch the Vikings win
over the Saints yeah and then I was at
the 49ers game oh I mean I was at the
bar and I showed up four hours early and
I don't drink anymore I quit drinking so
I just sat there just like a weirdo
because that was the only one there and
then just drinking water and tears tears
on the rock tears on the rock yeah but I
mean a lot of people give cousin's flak
but I like cousins okay you know well
look I mean it was a it was a fun season
and
you got into the playoffs and you got to
stay with your friends in Minnesota and
yeah it was nice hirato we had a book
somebody else last minute and it's fine
though it's really fun who's your book
who didn't we book Chris who did we book
uh Jerry Cantrell of Alice in Chains oh
that's cool
cuz he wanted his he want he's a big
Seahawks fan oh really yes we wanted to
get somebody whose team was in the
playoffs yeah I picked them too I just
really hope the Packers don't win why is
it because I hate them I got it now
right yeah so you know but Nick you're
not one of those guys like they beat us
in the division we want to see the NFC
North do well because if they do well it
makes it makes it look good on us that
no you're shaking your head no no I want
them to never win another game ever ever
again I hope they never win another game
I have I just out we just really don't
like the Packers Chicago I don't mind
Chicago's a great city I have family
from Detroit so I don't mind the Lions
but we all don't like we all just really
don't like the Packers they're just
really just a horrid place how quickly
did you have to did you warm to Brett
Favre then I warm to Brett Favre the one
specific play everybody was very
trepidatious but Minnesota's so nice
it's like it's really annoying I mean
it's nice but it's annoying ok so
everyone's like Oh Favre oh I don't know
maybe
and then that play against the 49ers he
it's just a bullet into the end zone
it's the most psychotic play it was like
a 55 yard bullet right to win the game
after being down really I know yeah it
was insanity and right then I felt like
I was converted and everybody was just
totally on board it was so awesome and
he should have won a Super Bowl that
year by the way that play I don't know
if you've been able to catch any of the
NFL 100 all-time team shows that was on
NFL Network but for the court did you
watch this - Chris he brought up Favre
brought up that play when he got into
the NFL 100 all-time team really yeah
yes well the way he brought it up is
that
when we talked about the confidence that
quarterbacks need to exude in the pocket
or we need to exude in the huddle and he
was talking about this with Brady saying
how sometimes though you know we're just
humans where we'll go out there on the
field and say to everybody in the huddle
okay we can do this but deep down you're
like we have no shot brought up that
total sequence where they were down the
whole game they had to drive the length
of the field with no timeouts and he's
like going in a lot going on okay guys
we got this and he's thinking to himself
is going on like I don't know how we're
gonna do this yeah and he threw that
ball literally most of half of the field
right into the back of the endzone into
the hands of a guy whose name I
completely forget Greg Lewis was like
what like number five on the depth chart
on that on that team yeah literally
receiving list he probably even know who
Greg Lewis was for like a month before
no he yeah he brought that he brought
that play was insane if you haven't seen
it look it up it's it's and it's a just
a rocket it's it's really insane and
then you know and then we got we got
taken out by the Saints and that led to
the whole mess with them but right on
the NFC Championship game yeah their
Karma it's really great I have a lot of
Saints fans I like New Orleans LA I'm
sure you do I'm looking at your list
here you're not heading there though in
the next couple of weeks and months I've
got Nick Swardson here on the Rich Eisen
show your next your next tour date is
Tampa Super Bowl weekend Super Bowl
weekend some of my agents angel he teed
me up to be in Florida for the Super
Bowl weekend just in case of Vikings
played so I have that Sunday off but I'm
doing shows Tampa improv that Friday
Saturday 31st and first yeah you know
about the Super Bowl is in Tampa next
year though you know so you're are you
what yeah so you're gonna have a stay
the Tampa Bay improv January 31st 2022
January 31st lie in my chair I'll be
sitting there the entire time yeah so
you're that you're and then you're going
to the Chumash casino here in Santa Ynez
California funny bone
in Columbus Ohio where I've got a big
following being a Michigan guy yeah so
what do you think makes the Super Bowl
who do you think makes the bowl here I
think it's really exciting I mean I'm
really pumped for the AFC yeah what a
crazy story both teams
I mean Tennessee and I picked them to
both games come on yes I did I'm so
pumped about that you in the variable'
family and the the Derrick Henry family
pretty much yes that's correct so when
they say when they look at each other in
the locker room and saying nobody
outside here believes in us that's
incorrect there's Nick Swardson there's
me and I'm not a jinx
no there's stories great and then the
Chiefs that was mental I mean Rob
riggles a friend and he was losing his
mind were you one of those people who's
texting them when they're dead when he's
down 20 no I don't text people during
games because it's super annoying
I get like tons of text where it's like
do that for sounds crazy I'm like yeah I
know just just watch again replay no
yeah so I just left him alone I
definitely don't pile on people during a
game if they're down I hate stuff like
that but I mean imagine going into a
game and being like okay even if we're
up by 24 we do not have this do not have
this all right what a panic attack when
when the Texans kicked the field goal
instead of going for it yeah I go up 24
nothing I thought that right then in
there I'm like man like that does feel
right like a mistake like that that just
that just screamed to me this could be
something to bite you and they you know
what even though it's insane to think
that shows you how key momentum is you
know it's a problem be important and it
was so early in the game - they went up
so fast I know right away so there was
so much game left and mahomes was like
we got this he was all fired up we can
do it and you just saw the tides turning
and I saw up when I was at the bar the
corner bar in Minneapolis ladies and
gentlemen and there was one Houston fan
I was watching the game in the sky there
was this dude he had jersey on and that
and I'm watching this guy and he was
really polite and he was just was
excited and then just deflated and I
paid for his tab yeah oh yeah put that
guy's tab on mine like I got it whatever
that whatever he wants for the rest is
it because he also was having water just
like you were I know this guy was going
for 24 that he's down 20 that will cause
any individual to reach for some
people's water so are you or so you
think the Chiefs and then that's a game
I don't know if I could call that one
either team I like on the AFC the Niners
because they beat us and San Francisco
is awesome and no Green Bay boo boo well
that'd be like for you watching a Super
Bowl with Green Bay in it that would be
an issue for you like literally would
you still watch the game where you would
I mean I would you still gonna watch it
in the bottom of a toilet okay so they
would have to put the TV over it okay I
mean I'll watch the game of course but I
don't know I know okay so you're kind of
like saying there's a total
superstitious guy right now sometimes
sometimes he runs through me he does he
just well I mean he runs through and I
was in uncut jumps a lot of people don't
know that I was the gem you you were the
uncut guy yeah yeah I was right that was
me was not in a movie with Kevin Garnett
in it I know but so he did say if he was
not nominated for an Oscar he would make
a movie so bad to get back and he said
it would be called grown ups three of
you can you give us any any he did say
he said that he would get back at the
movie business okay and something so
horrible and putting it out there all
right I'm sorry
there I just signed up there it is
grown-ups already read it there's no
there's no update on that situation you
haven't been reached out I just heard
everything we've grown up three he had
talked about it and then there was
another script out there that wasn't
approved and then there was another one
that just went viral that somebody wrote
that I thought was a hoax but I guess
it's real and I guess the scripts really
good okay and like that I don't know did
you hear about that it went viral some
guy some writer leaked it and and
somebody read it he said it's really
funny it's pretty hard are but he's like
it's really funny okay if I don't know
okay if you never know what's and it rip
I reprise any of your roles in many of
his films which one would it be
Nick Swardson I would say either that's
my boy where I played Kenny to do with
the mullet or just go with it where I
plays the Sheep ship out yeah Aniston
those were really fun even though I do
wear these crazy glasses that were like
triple coke bottle that hurt my brain
okay yeah those two are two of my
favorites all right well and I
appreciate you coming on here with your
jacket and your you've got you brought
your spirit man yeah this is my all the
Vikings University right and I majored
in sadness yeah you are aware though
that the Vikings are the first team in
NFL history with 30 playoff losses are
you aware of that fact I wasn't rich
don't shoot the messenger I guess I
shouldn't have said that when you
actually showed up here do you do you
have any thoughts I'm actually hearing
do you have any thoughts on the cheating
scandal in baseball you wanna I give you
the floor so you said you were bill burr
last night at a is it's after comedian
Bill burr yes lovely man some 20-plus
years yes and we always talk sports it
is podcast and it's supposed to be like
20 minutes and there's like an hour and
a half right but we were talking about
baseball and it's just depressing me so
many people are like everybody cheats
and it's like what nice well what if
they just didn't right just a pure
sports but he was bringing up the
steroid controversy when everybody was
roided-out and hitting
you know 480 home runs with one hand is
like yeah new sport and you know it's
just stuff like that is so absurd and
you know I just just go back to it the
way it was where they were chugging
whiskey in the dugout and chewing
tobacco smoking cigars walking out there
vomiting betting on ponies
yeah but not ponies on the side yeah
good Lauren let's go back to that maybe
that's a throwback we all need right now
that would be awesome that would be
another league no television sets no
nothing
yeah the radio right announcer with one
of those old-timey hats and a pipe and a
bowtie that's going back good to see you
Nick Swardson great to see rich I love
you thank you very patient you know dude
come on nick swardson dotnet is how you
can get tickets to see this man at the
tampa improv Super Bowl weekend the
Chumash casino right in the middle of
Presidents Day weekend and then in March
Columbus Ohio Colorado Springs Colorado
Salt Lake City and so much more nick
swardson dotnet at Nick Swardson on
Twitter at real Nick Swardson on
Instagram join the followers I'm I'm
following you sir I follow you Thank You
Reggie I follow you as well attaboy
that's Nick Swardson right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app